Jermaine told me one time he was at Red
Lion Pub with Knoxville back in the day
and Knoxville like unloaded his bladder
on Jermaine's back Jermaine was like
talking to somebody at the bar and then
like he feels like a little warmth on
his back that's like every time like
there were two things like my people on
fire yeah
yeah yeah yeah sometimes both
so like Jeff turns around and Knoxville
just unloads of his bladder like low
just like and Jeff said he he picked him
up and he like chucked him through the
bathroom door and started like [__]
clobbering him yeah and then they were
like people were like well I freaking
out he's like no this is my best friend
or whatever they went back to the bar
and drink yeah and I heard Jeff was in
Germany with bam one time and Bam like
peed all over this like techno Viking on
the dance when the guy didn't even
notice he was just getting drenched
there were many many games